bad trips
they're certainly easier to do in a
movie than good
trips i didn't see fear and loathing in
las vegas but everyone said
it proves again that it's very easy to
portray a bad trip i'm very hard to
portray a good trip
well they're all first of all i'll say
all the conventional things about
bad troops that you know
it's not always supposed to be easy that
uh sometimes learning curves feel very
unpleasant when they're unfolding
and uh we learn from our mistakes
and so forth and so on so then having
said all that
really what about bad trips well they're
horrible
bad trips make bad sex look like no
problem which is an amazing
thing to achieve
[Laughter]
i don't know you know the the
i guess part of the fun or part of the
challenge of being
psychedelic people is that our method
which is drop and weight uh
you you you never know you know you may
think you know uh and you may
do your rolfing and you're going to
gestalt and just
be scrubbed and drained and shined with
all your
enzyme systems up and going and it can
still
just chew your ass unmercifully
uh it's one of those places where i
who i'm not necessarily that uh
you know eager for astrological
explanations
reach eagerly for astrological
explanations because if everything else
is right
but and i've even noticed you know moon
in scorpio
for me is not a good time to
do psychedelics
i also you know i i
before a large trip i will throw the
ching
and without spending too much time on
the ching
i can't remember which hexagram it is
but
one of the 64 hexagrams says
uh inquire again of the oracle
if you have constancy something or else
something else something else
and almost invariably i mean i have no
idea how many times in my life
contemplating psychedelic trips i've
thrown
that hexagram the hexagram which says
ask again
and so then i ask again and if it's
negative i i don't do it i figure
you know you have right brain tools and
left brain tools somehow this question
about bad trips is about
your pre-trip intuition
feeling into the situation and then of
course there are obvious rules
i mean there are guaranteed situations
which gives you bad trips
i mean taking too much of a drug with
people you don't
know taking large amounts of the drug
and mixing it
with a lot of moving around in crowded
social spaces um
synergies are and synergies are simply
combinations of drugs
you know if somebody tells you they took
ecstasy and then they snorted some
ketamine and then they had a little
nitrous oxide
and some ghb this is god
knows i mean literally only god knows
because
no clinical medical research is ever
done
on stuff like that on the way people in
the street
actually take drugs is never studied
by medical science and synergies
are where the strange things
the dangerous stuff happens the heart
fibrillations
the convulsions the convulsive vomiting
the states of disorientation prolonged
states of sleeplessness
all of these things so
you know my attitude toward avoiding bad
trips
is for social purposes
raves and beach parties and
whatever low doses
you know it's a almost a true
or it is a truism but if you if you want
to
come down from a drug whether a
psychedelic drug or any other drug
the very best thing to do is furious
exercise
you know the guy who throws himself in
the icy lake and swims across it the guy
who chops two
cords of wood to come off some bender
well then a a dance club
is almost like the perfect social
situation designed to
shorten a drug trip and dampen the
effects
but people are such social creatures
you know i've said in many many times
over the years to the point where it's
almost
the mechanic method although how you
could think something so simple-minded
was a method
was like the way to take psilocybin for
example is
take a stiff hit like five grams if
you're 145 pound person
on an empty stomach and lie still in
silent darkness well this is almost the
opposite of
you know and the idea is you don't want
you want to concentrate on the thing
itself which is the drug
projected against the black screen of
your mind
you don't need doof coming in
you don't need smart drugs you know all
of these things are actually
distractions
and i think people don't are
so reluctant to follow this advice
because
they actually have no faith in the drug
they think they will be bored they think
well if i
did that nothing would happen well
i'm telling you you know it's for
ordinary people isn't that what we said
this stuff is not for the swamis they
have their own methods
this is this is for the great unwashed
masses of spiritually seeking humanity
so lay down in silent darkness
and take a look
and then if the trip is really bad then
there are things you can do while it's
happening
that are helpful
the most obvious one is
or the most effective i don't know if
it's the most obvious but i really
believe
it's the most effective is if you get
into a place that you don't
like uh and it's not physiological it's
not that you're having convulsions or
vomiting it's just that you're having
thoughts which alarm you
you should sing uh
you can make whatever shamanic hash of
this you wish
but the basic concept is to oxygenate
your brain
there's something about bad states of
mind on psychedelics are
very frequently in my observation
accompanied by shallow breathing
people get you know when you thread a
needle
everybody holds their breath nobody can
thread a needle without holding their
breath
it's like keeping your eyes open while
you sneeze
a person a human being cannot do this
so when we are really following our
thought
at the level of threading a needle we
stop breathing
and if you're not paying attention this
can go on for
minutes this very shallow breathing you
know you're not
breathing dude so uh
and and so what the thing to do is to
sit up
and uh you know your favorite shamanic
chant uh fleetwood mac recitation or
whatever just belt it out it doesn't
really matter i mean it may matter
i mean if you choose certain mantras or
something
you know haystacks will burst into flame
but
you know and there's no obligation to be
aquarant or hip either you know it
doesn't have to be
aphex twins it can be uh row row row
your boat
i've always preferred because it does
contain the refrain
merrily merrily merrily merrily life is
but a dream
if you're loaded on psilocybin or
ayahuasca the thought that life is but a
dream opens ahead of you
and becomes epiphanous instead of
ridiculous
but nobody does this a lot
who doesn't then occasionally put in a
very difficult evening
and you know part of your psychic
i guess your shamanic constitution is
how
quickly can you come back from a really
bone shaking psychedelic experience
either because
it blew your mind in some way or
something
appalling happened i remember
i mean i remember a number of
psychedelic trips that were hard to come
back from but i remember
one in particular years ago where my
friend and i took a lot of acid
and and
late in the trip like about 3 30 in the
morning
he had a very dramatic epileptic
seizure and i had never seen an
epileptic
seizure and um
oh god it just set off this cascade of
hysterical activity
the car the the 911 people
had to be called i remember there was a
real moment of truth in all this for me
i remember
the apartment was on the second floor
and
and i saw the cop cars and everything
pull up in front
we had flushed staggering amounts of
dope
knowing that they were about to arrive
and i went tearing down to the front
door and i was completely loaded on acid
and i could barely
stand and i could see through the glass
this
the cop and he said open the door
locked the door earlier and he said open
the door so i
fumbled with the door for a few seconds
completely
hysterically and ineffectively and then
i couldn't get the door open
so i stepped back from the door and said
shoot the lock off
[Laughter]
and then i realized dude
get a grip
you're going to have to um you know
this is handed in the wrong direction
and the cop was like
[Laughter]
so then and and then i remember you know
this trip to the hospital
and and uh i don't know what was going
on
it was herrick hospital it was in
berkeley which was also a mental heart
this bed me standing at the end of the
bed
trying to figure out is he dead is he
alive what does this mean
who am i what's going on and then there
was a person
who was obviously an inmate of the
stranger
wards of this mental hospital
who was washing the floor with this big
mop
and sort of waltzing around us with this
crazy expression and leaning over and
looking at me
and looking at him and i just didn't
know whether is this
really happening and if it is happening
why is
it happening and if it isn't happening
why do i think
this is what's happening and
and then i like finally the doctors
threw me out of there and i just walked
the streets of berkeley for hours and my
mind was like spinning just saying
something terrible has happened
something terrible
terrible terrible has happened and it
took
days to to you know realize yes
he had an epileptic fit here's what an
epileptic seizure is
here's the drug here's the prognosis
here he is
seemingly all right he came through in
much better shape it seemed than i did i
mean i was
deeply spun by all of this crazy shoe
and that's not an out of control drug
story i mean
truly i'm a very conservative person so
for me that was an
evening really getting beyond management
but some people you know start out like
that
i had friends in the 60s in new york
city who would say you know
in manhattan they would say let's take
500 mics and
hit the streets and mess with people's
minds well
can you quickly discover there are
people out there capable of messing with
your mind and
more than your mind and but sitting up
all night in manhattan diners just
taking on all comers
for mind games is you know no way
to spend anything
anyway so much for the question what do
you do about battery
you have character you live through them
and after a few months go back to it
many people it it's a bad trip that
finishes
for psychedelics and i don't think you
know you're ever really a mean to it
the funny thing about psychedelics i
think especially psilocybin i've noticed
is
it's incredibly gentle with beginners
it almost never bites a beginner you
know these
clueless people who go to it with knees
knocking
usually you know the doors of heaven
open and they're sweating
it's the veterans it's the old
battle-scarred
explorers who you know come back from a
certain given evening with their eyes
bugging and a tale to tell
[Music]
you